meine Damen und Herren hören Sie eine
Ansprache des Klicks Moderators Christop
krachten heute will ich mal dieses
unglaubliche Portal Chat R ausprobieren
wo man mit irgendeiner Webcam irgendwo
auf der Welt verbunden wird
Moment mein
erster please switch
on mein Gott t bist du das ja ich bin
willst du doch eine Frau sein FST du
doppben bist
ja fragen über Fragen und noch mehr
Fragen könnt ihr Stellen genau denn
White tity ist bei klickzoom und wie
immer könnt ihr Fragen als Kommentare
oder im Video stellen wobei Christoph
denk daran meist gibt es so viel
videofragen dass die kommentarfragen gar
nicht beantwortet werden können stimmt
ja also videofragen werden bevorzugt
aber man den ein oder anderen Kommentar
die guten die fischen wir uns auch raus
also jetzt einfach Kommentar schreiben
und oder ein Video anhängen so geht das
also haut rein wir sind gespannt genau
TC wir sehen
uns